Ось що стається, коли з великого міста
не вивозиться сміття.
Мешканцям не залишається нічого іншого, як вирішувати проблему власноруч.
Активістам реально набридли
чвари влади.
Львівські  політики говорять, що в нас є блокада зі сторони Києва.
Київські політики говорять, що в нас є безвідповідальність
нашого мера тут, на місці.
Я не хочу вдаватися в деталі, мені насправді це
нецікаво. Я просто хочу жити в чистому місті.
Львівська влада стверджує,
що в ескалації сміттєвої кризи винен Київ.
Мер Садовий скаржиться на політичний тиск.
Місто Львів є одне з найкращих міст в Україні.
У нас дуже якісно все функціонує.
Але якщо будь-якому містові України ви завтра перекриєте
полігон, куди вони будуть сміття вивозити?
Завтра на коліна можна поставити любе місто.
Львів - туристична принада України
зі старим містом, що належить
до спадщини ЮНЕСКО.
Близько 2,5 мільйонів туристів
відвідали минулого року місто,
відоме своєю польською, австрійською, єврейською та українською
культурною спадщиною. Тепер старовинний Львів
потерпає від сміттєвої кризи.
Репутація міста псується.
Люди говоритимуть про це не лише в нашій країні,
але й за кордоном.
Криза розпочалася минулоріч після пожежі
на Грибовицькому сміттєзвалищі, що призвела до його закриття.
Відтоді Львів залежить від "милості"
сміттєвих полігонів інших міст.
Дедалі більше львів'ян у розпачі:
вони протестують, блокуючи сміттям вулиці.
Зі сміттям - проти сміття.
Хочемо, щоб прибрали це сміття,
зробили санітарну чистку дороги,
щоб було мешканцям вільготно жити.
Тому що рахунки ми
сплачуємо постійно, щомісяця.
Заборгованості в нас не було.
Біля кучугур сміття – вдень мухи, вночі – щурі.
Лікарі застерігають від поширення інфекцій.
Літня спека погіршує ситуацію.
То ж неможливо, цілий тиждень оце... Мухи.
Щурі уже бігають тут.
Це просто неможливо. Антисанітарія.
Заважає. Неприємний запах у Львові. Не вивозять сміття.
Львівські сміттярі
заледве можуть упоратися з ситуацією.
Регулярно сміття вивозили лише з лікарень.
Львівські активісти чекають на сміттєвіз.
Люди годинами збирали і сортували сміття.
Радує те, що
один із небагатьох позитивів
оцього колапсу, який стався у Львові, -
це те, що люди зрозуміли на собі,
до чого призводить недалекоглядність
в сміттєвій стратегії.
Кілька мішків сміття таки забирають. Бодай щось.
Принаймні декілька полігонів у регіоні
погодилися приймати львівське сміття.
Перше відчуття - це полегшення,
бо на вивіз збираєш свої точки постійні,
тобто
вже нема тих завалів.
Садовий погодився передати вивезення сміття в компетенцію області.
Чимало львів’ян вважають себе і місто
заручниками сміттєвої війни між їхнім мером і Києвом.
Однак переможців у цій війні не буде,
бо страждає імідж усіх сторін.